well do a cover song over okay
suspicious minds what's up fool what's
up fool podcast what's up fool
man we missed you guys last week man me
and Rodrigo Torres right here yeah man
misty misty Lisa right here man wearing
the Night of the Living Dead t-shirt the
they are the Dead t-shirt that's it also
that's cool we have east of the river
here welcome
Boyle Heights - yeah miss Carlito AB
don't sleep in the house all right
well sums day listen we have a little
party right here my daughter my good
soon a little kid I wanted my hair long
I would I never known it'll get the girl
to be like that I think you wanted your
hair short for a while like Dick Butkus
my hair was gonna come off feather back
look like a white-trash lady no further
back here bro like like a badass this
strange thing no we're straight it was
further back when it parts like this
came with an aura the Bacchus is bro
exorcist order hell yeah well that went
away and then people started dressing up
either going to the club with flat tops
no spiky hair bro Zeke mmm right try
that [ __ ] bro and my hair would spike up
everyone liked that curly hair bro
everybody else had strayed you know let
you straight spiky hair I had [ __ ]
curls
yeah actually started curling when I
grew it long this week man we're in San
Francisco man at the Warfield theater at
8 o'clock here's a lineup man we got a
couple of people that I'm gonna
because they hooked me or back in the
days you know you don't forget
[ __ ] that paid you chump change
you know but you just need to do the
show but these guys actually came
through like sometimes you're sitting at
home like marriage is like you start
we're evaluating your life by thinking
about man this [ __ ] man you stuck with
your finances in your head you're never
gonna hang myself this real quick then
along comes a dude with a gig and when I
was in Last Comic Standing I'm I was
cash poor all my money was at NBC was to
holding it so I had no money so then
butch Escobar's saying [ __ ] all the time
Jody is cancelled probably couldn't make
it I [ __ ] got stuck on a flight from
[ __ ] uh Cuban Australia so we got
Bush Escobar's opening up this show well
do a choice gonna bring them up and then
we have Johnny rookie and then we have
Lydia Popovich Lydia Popovich and hater
Tuesday and hater Tuesday she's very
funny she's very very funny man
then after that we're gonna go to San
Diego Toby Hicks was good but before
then I heard you up toward the radar in
the Frisco game yeah
tell me find out it was you know you
could do that we're gonna go to the
we're gonna go to the one of the most
saddest games in the NFL the 49ers who
are one in seven versus the Oakland
Raider who are one in seven they're
trying their battery for last place
Tibet it's a battle the Battle of the
baby bro those takers bro are more
expensive than the takers were for the
[ __ ] your wrath versus a Green Bay
Packer this week at the Coliseum [ __ ]
Rams are seven eight and over they were
trying to give away they drop the prices
there were three times more I still
won't go much $79 not man is three
has more they have 240 I heard it any
dollar to set way way on top [ __ ] shit's
expensive we can't party in the bay with
20 bucks bro so we'll be at the game man
look for us man look for us we're gonna
be walking around and looking freaky
we might dress tougher though for the
game on my chest I think I am I'm gonna
be like meet your face
yeah if I paint my face is that
appropriation appropriation in the
breakout only appropriation if you're
out there paying people faces dread to
be a Rasta man yeah man appropriating
somebody else's culture I know - you
know why bludgeoning it's about the old
man what do the TT oh man has blue eyes
yeah
a lady one time over some lady one time
showed me her Halloween costume with her
husband and they were both cholos
horrible choice they're like 40 50 year
old white people you better find a safe
zone Wow well you know what man
blood in blood I have crossed over to a
lot of people all over the world [ __ ]
distribution I'll get your ass all over
stole a beer San Diego to Bob or theater
okay my San Diego eight o'clock every
Saturday November 3rd Toledo Ohio
November 8th through the 10th
that's right man we're gonna be cold in
Toledo man Buffalo New York
whoa watch out colder today is 43
degrees there but it feels like 32 I
can't feel my tongue was gonna be a
Tobey Hicks I better just for the comedy
we're gonna turn into a popsicle fool
he's skinny bro he's real
there is really no like no fat
November 16th to the 18th and helium
comedy club helium if I go to Niagara
father throw Toby over thrown about the
window miss might take that also Tempe
Arizona what champion zone of December
7th through a 9th I think that Thursday
Friday Saturday Friday Saturday Sunday
Friday Saturday Sunday there that will
sell out so get your tickets early that
will sell out my like so lead Ohio
Denver Colorado well for listen for
Toledo or Buffalo we can give you free
tickets if you're in that area if you
email fans at Felipe's worldcom only
those shows because you know we're
building that market so we've got free
tickets yeah this goes out for everybody
who wants to come over from Toronto and
drive two hours or three hours to
Buffalo Toronto people have a stroke
Anita Anita Canada Canada what's up
Toronto all that area Brantford if you
want to come to the short man we got you
bad bring your passport you know thank
you for coming on that video we got the
Lord he came through super clutch all
these shoutouts to that video pool is
gonna be a video everybody gets [ __ ]
up a couple showed up with no sleep bro
and a lot of tequila a real and they
pass it around overlooking the man who
brought their dad mother sad uncle man
shouts out to the homies who are driving
the whips though yeah I get it all right
those drivers
[ __ ] even a little large-headed on
Bourbon is gonna be drinking so yeah
that was very nice of him to just showed
up and you know that very kind
yes I'm Eric Ballard I'm bill burr and
our magical they started the audience
Comedy Network and now I'm I think bill
burr and Matt al Madrigal and Bert
Kreischer are like board members so like
they made a bed board yeah they made it
man so things are happening man swingers
club and champion Gentile birthday Omar
Gonzalez you already asked for their
level you sharpening that knife right
now he's off Hilo so uh very much you
got dry bronies in there I don't want to
go there number I think if I were to go
there now piyah depress bro see you
don't age where I'm not turned on me by
five guy who won what sad woman but you
think about it when you go to at the
swingers bars I don't want to go there
where we just guys like who look like me
bro I want to get grossed out by me
being there I don't want to be grossed
out by other people I just don't you
know it's bad
yeah cuz I'm being like a goofy like I'm
the only one that nasty they're like
everybody's gonna look in it and in
shape and look at me go oh it's cool he
showed up but I don't want to go to a
place like a swingers place where
everybody knows I mean Rodrigo and a
chance to let me Rodrigo first of all
how they're though I'll be like I'm
gonna be like them and if I go it'll be
nothing but hot chicks everything
swingin everybody charges oh yeah
exactly exactly bro that's why girls
bars man woman gotta be like keep in
there for after the wreck [ __ ] so we
think over the head I heard the swingers
bar right there in San Bernardino
Riverside San Bernardino right there by
Cal State somebody know but if you go in
there with a girl and she's hot you only
have to pay 70 bucks
but if
go there biters you can't go there by
yourself but for a guy it's 150 200
bucks
well my prizes waiting up I was at Tempe
it was $40 for a guy how do you know
that one was Darren Carter
oh it was that boy wearing his [ __ ]
unless your shorts are wearing of the
little Daisy do we trust from rows of
our high school bro that wasn't no what
like early 2000 I don't have no
underwear one time bro dude I guess you
know put on those shorts bro for
underwear for to go to school for I was
walking brother I somebody side of my
started I had a rash underside of my die
bro I asked swimming trunks oh but I
don't know where they whose daring
Carter's that's what I find sound like
what he was saying know the story we got
a 2001 back to like the early years of
sleep in the seventh day like Keith ball
Schwartz do shorts
yes wingers man they're everywhere
though right
but do there have to be enough to kill
women who are at those swingers clubs
are usually there because of their men
oh not for coerce and then they're like
oh gross not gonna be with this guy like
I got a play too
you know as the plays I walk in and I
see Mega Man pushing a push broom
there was a merge for that place well
he's saying I would break her all those
was in high school there was a family
that we knew this fool his parents used
to be swingers back in the day and then
the guy that they used to swing swing
with came back and took his mom and they
left the dad
yeah Sweeny don't be working out who you
put out in the market like yeah you
can't be throwing your lady out there
like that man not even man
not even day to the back boo oh man also
December 31st I'm gonna be in Denver
Colorado at the Paramount Theater that's
gonna be fun New Year's Eve yeah man
you gotta join your beers everybody now
I'm good right now I was gonna a little
plug the little Riverside show everybody
website ie please come out to people of
jokes November 13th the big IE yeah man
a p.m. Inland Empire yeah my business
take two ie well [ __ ] started
what a jail should were you from the
home state Boyle Heights that's the [ __ ]
that I got for the video that was a one
thing that people were talking [ __ ] like
only little thing was the Boyle Heights
come on they have those fights on his
thing anytime if you even just let's
slip easter later like Boyle Heights is
not and then a bill in the comments did
my little boy Heights and it ended with
I was at the border of Bordeaux has in
East LA doing a video which is right
there with the snow cones are that's the
border of that right right when you pass
that you're officially snow cones you're
in Boyle Heights but if you go down that
guy's okay but if you go down to like
Whittier that's what the sign really is
where do you write with your in India
yeah that's where I'll say welcome to
say they're from weeks la they're not
even from East LA from El Sereno dicen
up hours
come on you're too [ __ ] far away but
I mean you don't have any overlap with
people that are from East LA they say
they're from Boyle Heights always like
someone from what way for me you know
it's more familiar people want to get
super technical Rydberg a baggie like
though right like BHA BHT is right so
even within that this will be like [ __ ]
Boyle Heights but they live in Boyle
Heights but they're not talking about
high but that's the thing though dude I
think if you keep on doing it you know
people are you break it down though you
do I am football well you said I got
some world like I said well - like where
is that I go it's East LA it's on inside
of LA okay see somebody we were coaches
here watching bird doo-doo
what's the place between East LA and
Commerce in industry City of Industry
that's in between right no no no that's
our commerce Montebello easterly and
burning south get good Maywood that's
what that turn of Boyle Heights East and
we're having the gate we're at King Taco
and I said is the best taco the dstyle a
right now in Boyle Heights but we're
actually in East LA and I were a flock
was shows up [ __ ] your homes this is
east los anyway that I love east los
shirt and I wearing a Boyle Heights
shirt but when you give interviews and
stuff around the country you're right
the people always think you la because
they know East LA from movies and TV you
know it's you know the movie took place
in Boyle Heights right they all still
identify and finally do a movie where
you right there right by your mom's
house yeah but that's more older fools
doing that [ __ ] who's there probably
like get it they're like that's right I
used to be tough yeah now they want to
be tough on the right and but it's all
sort of like those fools that have that
beef with set up Travers in Brooklyn
when they say I didn't call me from Hyde
Park bro North East Los Angeles say well
North East Los Angeles Highland Park HOV
HP is hunting yeah the park wasn't built
in a day bro
it just looked that way vegan restaurant
we had as his show was located at right
Haile Park
well they do pop up so I was so full
special rest in peace shoutout to off of
Pam's father Abel more de Abril Mona
what's up homie who passed away last
week he was a big fan Qing Feng - he was
a big and and she likes to listen she
listens to the podcast
she's a listener
he was a big fan to listen to him he's a
big fan and she listens to the pot okay
he was a big fan and she listened to the
podcast yeah her dad was a big fan of
your comedy podcast more rows shot down
Kim Morra I'd shot at beta you know
where your glasses beta at beta seven
the word 7 and the number 7 that's a
confusing one I will Maura and for him a
you get older married he talks to Sifu
from high school pass it out but then
you scan your Facebook and it always
used to meet this full time I thought he
liked me no more I know he was dead last
couple years been my most deaths I've
seen in forever doc yeah okay
everybody's dying on healthy foods too
dog oh yeah he was an athlete you seem
like you're all fat and cheer so you're
[ __ ] you're dead at 50 dog [ __ ]
skinny fool doing backflips all dead
what was he 40 he was 15 43 44 mr.
booties are saying yeah he was young huh
when you were all a little kid you'd be
like he's for dead [ __ ]
oh I know a little kid people died at 70
bro people died of natural causes at 70
but now 40 anybody know kids dying and
that's what caused another to bro I
getting shot we're dying where they were
older when we're little were people of
natural causes
and now fools are [ __ ] up with fast
food and drugs yeah I was having a
procedure of a few weeks ago see teacher
and the guy in the bed next to me on
that we're waiting for surgery moved in
the hallway with his wife now he wasn't
morning who's an older man tell me more
about how merry
yeah not you you don't follow the
category so what anyway the guy the
doctors were talking about like they
were worried a little bit because his
arteries were so hard like he was having
a heart surgery but like they were
worried about like the actual like blood
and like putting the IVs in and all that
stuff that his arteries were so hard but
it's all from those who do that homeless
guys all about heart if he wasn't even
fair man what's up hey you're a comedian
I got some jokes for you mr. baza amen
what did one that saved the other nut
what that [ __ ] in the middle think
he hard sell me joke's on you don't tell
anybody I told you that should they go
take I'm Kato that's what a comedy club
hey but if a homeless person told me
that joke you gotta give them a dollar
on the radio what happened with radio
and we had that Louie and that fool was
driving it with his wife and they you
know he lower window real hard [ __ ] they
just started walking to worse save
yourself
so did we give it in here happy birthday
man how'd you know my birthday I didn't
know I'm here to collect on free tickets
what we more free ticket mais my to take
it to my comedy show tonight lady come
no no I probably did we but they look
like Marvel's didn't have nothing to do
on that so
I'm gonna take you out babe probably
ended up getting loaded before the show
in this past I pulled over to give that
for that roach I bet you got put over
that rose you got two strikes start to
work but one bear the guys over there ah
two guys over here
Mexican city and Rodrigo gave them tips
on getting the bait pen through I gotta
answer those questions you know the real
quickness what's the wildest questions
you've gotten as a rep and artists from
art is or from a fan I mean people like
wild [ __ ] oh wow this [ __ ] like
advisable to type of adviser like can I
sleep in your studio or can I you know
borrow something that I'm got something
like that you know people perceive
different [ __ ] and they just think like
oh you got it you can hook me up I don't
think I've been asked anything crazy
it's kind of similar I think people just
kind of assume certain things I mean
I've been asked like rude [ __ ] naked
pictures oh yeah there were people like
there was one guy who pretty much said
that I will never forget it - he he told
me that he respected me so much as an
artist that he wanted to please me
orally and I was just like thank you
good that delete block combo from me you
know at that point but I mean like
something that crazy crazy that people
have asked is like can you hook me up
with this can you do like just pretty
much asking for like a handout almost
like yo I see that you work with this
person can you link me with that person
can you make this pretty much make this
move for me and at this point I'm just
kind of like dude I'm looking for
and the random nudes from that I've
never asked for from isn't that good
news but I get like a whole chapter
letter of movie ideas though that are
ridiculous start opposite Bruce Willis
Batman Roach who don't even make music
are like I have a song concept for you
to kill Siri - from platform kill see
ray just recently though some this is
actually like just within this week some
random person who I have no idea who
they are sent me a declaration of
independence oh [ __ ] things I need to
work on as an artist Quincy Jones
that's crazy a declaration hollow the
declaration of independency I don't even
know four score and seven years I don't
know it started off - with like I don't
want to sound like a [ __ ]
start out we award Invitational whoa
[Music]
she's your biggest fan girl I post if I
post a picture a selfie I'm not even
anybody okay I'm not trying to be
anybody at all you Lisa producer of the
front of the scene you know yeah so so
I'll get a comment from a woman usually
you know when I had those silver hair
with their little purple she goes you
know you look so much better with the
blonde Oh like I don't even know this
would involve me but women are really
looking for these flaws like you could
be so much better if reverie gets that
same thing at home with no man I think
it's like we have a lot of
self-confidence and we love what we do
and I think a lot of people can come and
like I just think that it's what the
thing it the thing it is is it triggers
my memories of my mother talking about
my hair and I just want to punch this
baby's everybody I grew up with this
complex for my mom I don't need it from
the strange they would never do that
from for people they know but a stranger
alter they'll just like feel free to
give you they would never see it in
person oh yeah she would never tell me
that in person back in the day before
the internet I have people tell me that
all that [ __ ] in purse they like this
listen man we don't have social media
right now but you should do it more
jokes about letter tell you what you
should rap about like no tell me I think
we should do more Joe's about Rob you're
not an artist that come bro you're gonna
mention though caravan as a rock how
could I make the caravan funny bro dude
I don't do you guys get in cuz you're
Millennials to use that word but do you
guys get other people your age like
coming down are you about lyrics that
might be offensive
or things that you'd say [ __ ] that
might be like crossing on line or you
get because sometimes you know we see
that coming honestly I feel with like
the way the climate is right now with
music is everybody just says anything
they want so there's nothing we could
say that anybody hasn't heard right so
we don't really get that a lot from your
fan base at all like like they like you
they're going along liking you and then
all of a sudden you say something or you
put a song out that oh you know what I
think that's misogynist or whatever you
know it's pretty crazy I think that even
how it is today there's people who just
are so tuned out that they don't even
realize what they're really saying you
know so we see different degrees of
emcees and the dudes who are like you
know this song is called suck my dick
[ __ ] this and that there's a new song
oh my god is a new song and like old a
song I chopped onion chop oh yeah it's a
good song I think kiddo and I kind of
kind of heard some guys with some of our
lyrics cuz we definitely has like I have
a lion where it's like if you taking
care of him that ain't your lever that's
your son and then she has a line where
it's like how you grabbing on your dick
but don't know how to grab a mic and
when she says that line you literally
see all the guys go like yeah I actually
do know how to my girl yeah how she
learned all those tricks man they're
crazy well every damn I give in to that
[ __ ] to and if you listen to him go back
and forth the whole thing is just like
[ __ ] up dude
see criticisms like this can't even
drink a [ __ ] Corona without somebody
saying I needed a drink Pacifico
everybody wants to coach
I'm here man since uncle speaking of
fire departments no you said they're
extending as contact I want to see this
guy live away
do you think they got ice a big dick guy
did you plug it into this thing I don't
have Boombah choppin yeah
there's still music you know he gets
away with it cause it's - yeah other
foods that the shows aren't as art as
musical or as being creative is this
that's right right as I say Millennials
I don't think we get it at all like
people say [ __ ] you would not believe
like yeah add some of the shows that
were a lot of your shows are like kind
of underground and it's like a scene of
its own it's HIPPA like it's not like
it's not pop hip-hop so [ __ ] a lot of
those people that talk a lot of [ __ ]
online don't go to those they're not
part of the community because they were
you'd be sitting on stage somebody said
that you probably talk and there's
booths that come out from the keyboard
and then try to rock the show and try to
spit the [ __ ] that they've been only
telling to themselves they're like one
other duties hyping them up and they
kind of these show and I'm sure you see
it in comedy too and people think they
could do it and then they just blah all
right on your face and it's like what
chili dog or bang everybody would happen
to me bro well they might show mercy at
all when somebody invited a bunch of
college students bro they give a class
what call it what class these kids were
in Oh sensitivity and diversity
let the college class there take it you
have a kid to my Sony weapon a wok table
tyranny and diversity but they walked
out because they understand my jokes but
see they're really really into
sensitivity diversity they wouldn't
notice that there was no diversity in my
show with our Latino and they were never
dividend then she should've trying to
investigate why why because I'm not
coming essential because I never been
allowed to get a Comedy Central I never
been allowed you know to open to be to
be with other the white comedians who
are my friends
some have always been like not allowed
in that's what they should be focusing
on that's why my life my audience are
Latino
they're trying to create a fictitious
issues issued over London sighs he's
anti-trans some people were triggered
because of this thing
you know domestic violence jokes working
a new joke it's a joke and it's hard to
say that it's a domestic violence joke
but it is and it comes from a true story
it the story is almost absolutely true
from the point of view of him as that
what you were 8 or so during that but
it's a sad story but he has learned to
talk about it in public 40 years took
him a long time to talk about this and
it's the comics used comedy as therapy a
very often you know and a lot of them
have been joke this is cheaper than
therapy whatever they get up there and
just blab about the problems but out of
that tragedy comes comedy you know and
you have learned to find some comedy in
it and as someone who has abused as
child as well I know I think it's very
funny and I love that Jay I think that
like when you when you said that joke if
I'm if I'm remembering the state
flashbacks happening from that time that
was a great opening joke because
everybody was dying because they could
relate yeah you know and I see why like
especially a group of people our age
because a parent you know it's obvious
we're the most easily offended and what
city was this in Seattle but listen but
they drove down from Portland where they
go to school at Evergreen which is with
the most PC liberal college in the
United at the Novo class and also like
you're saying that's a relatable joke to
people who grew up in that background
which a lot of us have neighborhood you
can grow up in that situation but yeah
it's sensitivity diversity right now if
my daughter was taking that class take
her out of college I mean it'd be like
you know what you're only allowed to
take one elective well I would've kicked
why are you taking that disgusting
comedian tell me that those kids are
that [ __ ] dumb that they came and see
through the [ __ ] that are being
[ __ ] tired and it's not even they're
not even creating this you're going
along with something that's been in the
somebody the sake of business now
somebody tweeted to him and this one of
the girls I was so scared the
environment was so scary
she could have come to one she was
scared at the show she said and she
tweeted that 10 years ago you a writer
I'm not a publisher I'm gonna put a
picture of me and then discussed a
comedy short depressed listen okay this
girl other girl who email didn't buy a
t-shirt this other girl who emailed me
she was from the group as well and she
said I think they're about 10 or 15 of
them nickimja certainly had me stable
she said she actually understood what he
was doing she got it right but her she
said a lot of my classmates didn't get
it and so half of them walked up a lot
of the LGBT students who were in our
class they were they were triggered they
were bothered by whatever so she she
said look she said but we're gonna talk
about it on Tuesday because that's when
their next class is tomorrow and we're
gonna discuss it and I just want to
bring something from Felipe's point of
view she actually was opening up to me
saying I want to be fair and I want and
she's sorry for this and she did say
that she wanted to bring light to these
people who are a part of academia who
don't really see the rest of the world
you know University she acknowledged
that these her friends are also
sheltered right that should have been my
response the [ __ ] is that kidney Mia but
anyway so I responded to her and I said
Felipe's not gonna respond to you and I
wrote her a long letter about everything
and I said but I want to give you a
picture of my writing tollbooth
send her that song suck my dick but I
wanted to so I wanted to respond because
I have a problem with these people okay
and I as a liberal that I've been in a
feminist for the last 26 years I
catching I can't take these new people I
can't they're too far they're removed
from society and I did say that that you
know the world is not safe and it's not
going to be fun or nice all the time and
that's something you're not going to see
in this college that you're in and this
is the world that's shaped Felipe you
know in these comics talk from their
point of view from how they grew up you
know and they get mad at you for
bringing it to light are using it in
your you know in your I can't take
somebody's walking around with that idea
made it if they're talking about your
university classes they're like magic
she just go to the best quarter of our
to [ __ ] there's gonna be some things
not smile in the future even last time
last night you did a fundraiser oh my
god a lot of liberals each other to our
mansion into a fight I don't want that
bros but some of these new liberals are
a little too far they were fighting for
Medicare bro
which is fine you know whatever but this
is about public it's a group called
Public Citizen and they fight for the
little guy against corporate interests
and all that so they've got a good cause
but others in anyway bill burr went up
before oh my god we killed people are
walking out they were really walking
yeah yeah his doctor he would hit this
man we had a good run right
you know he had a good point of view
because he's like he's like so are we
gonna just believe a hundred percent of
these women like you never met a psycho
[ __ ] who's trying to get revenge on
something you know like how about eighty
nine percent we believe disgusting yeah
like they're offended by that
conversation you know which is Wow
actually not far from what we should be
thinking are we going to believe these
women 100 percent you have to listen to
both sides that are we taking due
process out of all out of the picture
completely you know he had a point in
these people were just all they heard
was one thing relying he's going to get
some of them and then they hissed after
he walked and but when I went out when I
went up there she was still watching cuz
you with one of the walkers watching oh
so light through our heroine bro do the
show in temple last week there was an
old man on the Sunday with a couple like
of the wives just for Halloween you'll
say hell no [ __ ] it just let him this
[ __ ] I do like having the time of
his life Rosie I man I'm a nomad like
you know kind of similar to the things
you've said I've kind of bounced around
with in my childhood but I pretty much
uh was from I'm from like the six to six
rows mean area but I grew up in South
East LA in south
so shout out to 3 2 3 that's what
actually were a couple other people from
our group are from as well I actually
kind of knew them in high school and
stuff but yeah you're like people that
tell you my you representing our people
but you represent I'm more like some guy
goes man you representing for ugly fat
guys like me like to me like me huh you
got to get a stylist and I was like
rapper every at home girl they're just
like they got so much hate listen become
I mean know who you are spreading the
stereotyping that but also what about
Gwen Stefani's the Pendleton everything
is cool we were losers I get often like
it stereotype oh she's like you know
this chola she's in a gang or whatever
the case is but or like I've been told
that like I just like to get Oh or like
I should try and even by my parents like
you should probably like sharpen up your
look even more on like I understand to a
very large extent but like I'm also like
struggling as an artist like I don't
have this the all these lavish clothes
like and at the same time farmers market
but your guys this style is very
casual and laid-back it's not like
you're part like some of it people
commented on that about the video you
know this guy's not like sagging pants
or like any sort of gimmick or anything
a regular guy but no that's do the
compliment because the regular guys go
rap because your music is coming through
it's not about an image you know what I
mean it's just like I'm a regular person
I actually like did a battle a couple
years ago and all this girl could battle
about me with was how I looked
how I look and when I made jokes about
my weight like I pretty like my last
line of my battle was after we win this
[ __ ] we hitting up the food court you
know like just like trying to like put
like jokes on it but they're getting
good what are you gonna say that about
us more it's like you're like like big
guys like sometimes like I'm doing my
big joke about myself
people think I'm doing about them they
think oh he's he's bashing he's fat
shaming oh yeah but I you know you
comment well I'm fat I can't talk about
them being fat shame I saw there's
somebody piling these [ __ ] rules
I know to have no rules
[ __ ] like the image like he
says it perfectly in one of us and our
cipher like [ __ ] the image the image
doesn't even matter like you have fools
wearing like in by all means go ahead
but you have fools wearing dresses and
like women wearing absolutely nothing
like it could be so much worse in my in
my opinion but I think that like what we
offer is realness and even if we were
making a [ __ ] ton of money we would
still be dressing the same you know we
would it almost is like a sense of being
humble like I could definitely blow all
my checks on nice clothes for my shows
but for what yeah but your also respect
look on the streets too man I like you
guys dressing [ __ ] where he come from
yeah well we're lucky you're saying like
we do we do hip-hop you know we can't
get away with gimmicks especially
nowadays like people are so close to you
that if they know you full of [ __ ] right
here people are too savvy nowadays to
fall for [ __ ] like that you just got
the crass but I mean for the most part
you can right right that would a pH you
know what I'm saying
dope dope you'll pick on anything man oh
man why you got a missing weed again
this straight ace rappers right don't do
drugs
they're anti drugs right right or even
things we've done and if we're being
ourselves smoking weed or drinking one
right now people try to put us in that
box like all another rapper just getting
high I'm gonna hear that rap Sunday
after the show went home I know that's
the thing that comedy if you started
being more sensitive in your comedy he'd
be a TEDTalk it would what's up fool of
returner surely there were several deals
to I'm loud is his [ __ ] voice is too
loud his laugh is too loud put Ghibli's
to the mic don't give her the mic then
they say this is a gold digger right
take those shovels below show me oh yeah
I'm a gold digger 12 years ago and he
was living in a roach infested little
one efficiency apartment with mushrooms
growing in this town
we had no that wasn't easy and then when
you were all crack up that one time he
took my last $10 for gas money he took
it took it that was sad that happened
the day after Edwin called me and said
Lisa I told him I didn't have any money
he looked like me he looked at me like
he was he looked at me like I was the
devil Lisa I said I know that I said I
know that look if I still loved you and
then you came out the other side though
I'm not a gold digger funny people
[ __ ] little assumptions on social
media they know everything
no we entertain you all right yeah
people get so caught up with that social
media world that it just you know it's a
whole new reality to some people do
people write a whole rap so I said it to
you I had them do send me an entire song
like I want you to wrap this this would
blow up and I'm like you're [ __ ]
tripping you arch and he's like you just
put in a professional ATAR yeah yeah
that's true well you can't the people
will try to send scripts but now they
sent them to me or April your agent and
you have to say like we are not reading
this is unread it's unsolicited we can't
accept any unsolicited material you know
because if you do read it if he does
read it and then later on something
similar comes out that guy's like I sent
him a script in 2000 and he copied the
whole thing you know so I can't accept
any scripts I had a guy man like
forget this out that we're doing wild
coyotes and Gotham's and this guy random
guy this guy was just a regular worker
you know he works at a UPS regular Joe
he had an actual folder was typed up
whole movies temp as a 30 page movie
idea already with lines of what to say
and other lines were part of my jokes so
he wrote like like the dialog with my
material so they fill in the blanks
crime the movie starred Willie Barcena
Gabriel is yes people already attached
today but I was the only one who's been
attached he melded 20 bro and he starts
off Felipe Esparza works at the bus
driver for the MTA and then William
Stoller's gave her glasses and joy
Medina works as in in a gym somewhere
and Willie Barcena
works is where a security guard in a
school he took our stories and made into
a movie bro he's good at cutting and
pasting but like like he really like
typed it bro like really typed it and it
really got busy but he never wrote a
movie before because when I read a movie
the name really goes in the middle
so I his was like the word was right
here heroes like Direction direct action
is like okay right here man you will
yell cut and then we'll go to another
scene this is where you karate chop a
guy on the bus trying to get on free
will but then they said you stuff with a
but the rest you could just fill in the
rest you just fill in the empty parts
you know make it fun I had a crazy guys
open up and throw up at Burbank bro oh
yeah flappers that guy's number is in my
phone and his name is crazy guy from
flappers don't pick up I have to
remember who it is and he calls like
once a year and I'll see it pop up in
the middle the night hit a boob idea to
the black page mm-hmm mm-hmm he could
just fill in the funny the best joke
ever seen was Daymond way and he goes
man I got people
coming after me and back home with movie
ideas I got this guy came up to me and
the Queen they go through demon I know
you know you I know you know Hollywood
vampires vampires and then he goes they
give me the bat the pace of vampires and
then next pig was black black black
better black here's what happened once
the rest of the pages see that when you
put a lot of money to a vampire
conceptualist
now I gotta work for this movie that
[ __ ] some people think it's that easy
though you know people have no clue
anybody you write you write like movie
scripts and stuff no but we have ideas
yes and then we go to his agent say hey
we have these ideas and then next time
we find it right like we had an idea for
developing calm we ditch the sitcom this
year a few weeks ago based on our lives
together which to ABC NBC CBS and they
passed but now we're going to cable and
streaming but but they the thing is
there hopefully a couple Latino shows
coming out this fall or next fall I mean
the last time we're on the show looking
we had a different one I think no but it
was a yeah it was another show but it
was Paul Rodriguez I think called in and
was talking about yeah dropping some
knowledge he will guess the guess the
oil or something yeah so we were
pitching but what were you saying
we were talking or I forgot what I
brought that up for all we're developing
those ideas oh the idea so we'll take
ideas too we'll have an idea and then
the agent bring in some writers to Paris
with our production company to Paris
with and then we sit and talk and we
went through like four writers and
finally found the one
so it's hard to find a non-white writer
by the way that's a real challenge it
will hover cause Latino but even
non-white was hard to find
we had one non-white writer that we met
with we actually ended up working with
him he's the one but that's not why I
just wanted other perspectives it was
all 40 50 year old white men who were we
were meeting with and one of them we
started to go with but the network
wasn't confident with him so we switched
it out to a new writer and he had worked
for Jerrod Carmichael and stuff he's an
Indian guy and then he had been married
to a white woman so it felt like it fit
what our lives were like to understand
still pitch you were done you were done
shows where you show up and there's a
creep yeah it's funny you have family I
know you got a stalker fans that show to
all your shows like you're like oh man
only damn but this was good yeah I think
like I have a boyfriend now too and I
think a lot of full sam and they're like
oh like they don't they don't try but
they're gonna follow you no more
yeah-hoo yeah-hoo have came to my shows
or like or what's the funniest is when
they spit all this game on line they
like try and act like they're really
like into you as an artist and then you
see them in person and they're just like
too scared to talk to you sure like act
like you're not there and it's like okay
but like because they've done bad things
to you know they know you in a different
light you don't know it my when I first
got my my packages from my album I had
posters of myself and I'm you know kind
of
you can kind of see my shape and stuff
and just to look at some guys faces when
they bought them and just like the the
the the glow in their eyes I was just
like and then I think Hollow told me he
was like bro you know how many people
are gonna jack off to this picture and I
was like it's possible but to be honest
like even when people who have
approached me are kind of creepy I just
all I can really do is just like hi
thank you you know how you have to keep
composed I'm sure you get crazy as
people you know he's like you know fools
will be drunk and just crossing the
boundary as a guy let me salute you
feels bad ass breath oh the Mike's
laughter I showed JLo mildest spitting
on a mic we've definitely had some I
know all of us and like these guys to
have definitely had some drunk fools let
me spit you pause I spit some fire too
and you're literally and Jade rest in
peace J Dilla when he was rhyming as JD
he says something I'm sorry it's not JD
his gang star and he says fools coming
up to me after my set trying to like
come up in my ear spit something to me
with their hot-ass breath like all I did
back in the day was give people props
and wine and like it's true though you
will go to a show and there I can like
it's dope because I know that people are
trying to come out of their shell and
network and you know do things like that
but you can't be holding people
especially the people that are like your
if your entire face and body is telling
them that you gotta go and they're still
like you know kind of giving you their
CD and giving you ideas and like what
they're doing and I think they're just
kind of needs to be a balance of like I
hit me up on line shoot medium but I
gotta go you know but girls be creeps -
oh yeah creepy girls at the shows - like
it's easy to get in trouble as an MC
you're like you know but here's don't
see people speak on that but here's the
funny part before you guys will stop
talking to you because you have a
girlfriend girl
she's crazy so we try to the girls try
to step up definitely like they don't
when they find out that you got a girl
of course they you want a message you
might be always have girls coming up so
they'll teach you the game it's always
interesting though you know some go
there some go like the extra miles is
that like what is it like when they come
what do you say and have looked at don't
sleep in his eyes and then look at
someone and look back and look at
someone else because he's the only guy I
know that is like with it other fools
are stupid and get hella caught up but
are you props man you you you the
comment section blowing up right now
adults leave girls like what are you
talking about you gotta get him a little
doctor hat you were getting like a
letter for someone like a fan because
this a man I just started rapping and I
just I know you're gonna be performing
over here and I just want to know if I
can have like a moment by yourself just
you and I man just shoot ideas and maybe
you know if I let me know if I have a
chance that possible nothing crazy like
that instrument but I definitely get
some like do sometimes like yo like I
just started performing you think you
could give me like some pointers you
know and it's just because they have a
lot of people get like this whole image
like oh you're doing this you must be at
this level when I'm really at this level
you know it's all like it's all the
image but you know I still give them
like I've had dudes that like hey Mia
when I was barely starting and asked for
pointers and now I see them like rapping
and doing their thing and they still hit
me up to this day like y'all do like I
hit a like three different guys that day
and none of them responded to me but you
responded to me you know so it's cool
when that happens sometimes you know
because sometimes just give me like a
little advice makes all the difference
to somebody well you know like it's
almost like comedy is though like if
someone has to ask they're probably not
that great you know I mean you'll know
if you are because when you go on a
stage people laugh or when you go and
perform exactly so I always tell people
that do you think I'm dope can you check
this out I go do you think you're dope
as long as you think you're dope [ __ ]
what I think you go out there and do it
and people will recognize you you know
yeah cuz I've definitely had people send
me their songs and send me like what
they wrote and oh can you check this out
like see how you feel about it and do
you like it and that's like like he said
you know do you like your music do you
like what you're putting out because
ultimately if you don't like what the
[ __ ] you're put there and you shy or
this or that the crowds going to punch a
hole through their zoot suits so we will
just need to like just go there do it
huh yeah that's all you could do you're
only gonna find out by yourself you
don't eat you're headlining a show and
then you realize that the promoter like
you hired three other rappers you have
no idea who they are but they were you
- the rappers like to be their friends
they tell you yeah man who made us pay
to be on the show
oh it underground is infamous for pay to
play fools get run up I'm talking
thousands official $2,000 $3,000 the rap
community should just tell the other
rappers think there's a shortcut
especially the rapper with rich parents
they could buy all the equipment no cuz
there's booze that are like that's that
and they go up to a promoter like I
could get on this if you go to a
pay-to-play show majority of the lineup
is trash because they can't access their
own shows and I'm not gonna completely
flash merch be honest to be a thousand
percent
my first three big shows I opened up
formers I opened up four blue four blue
and exile and I opened up for sugar free
those are the only shows I have ever
paid for but it was a sick investment
because I got like 30 40 shows off of
those off of those shows so I understand
that but paying 50 bucks for every
single show in the - the promoters who
do the [ __ ] you're telling to this [ __ ]
though like we're someone else who
probably shouldn't be on that stage but
they got two grand or they come from
probably one privilege and they go and
then they they [ __ ] suck and they go
over their time yeah promoters though
who keep that predatory behaviour going
like I just want a little extra grease
in their pockets like we were talking to
Oh Danny loved though - Danny loved was
talking about the Sunset Strip and
having to pay the Troubadour and the
go-go whisky a go-go and all those
places to play during the hair band days
and you know Motley Crue and all that
stuff and the Guns and Roses days you
had to pay to play
and it was like bringer shows kind of
it's the same thing in comedy it's kind
of like paying your dues at that point
but I mean it's crazy to have to pay to
go up and or they do ticket sales where
you gotta buy that's what the 40 tickets
at you know for Tebow you know what
then the lineup is like 12 13 14 15
people and like you get there and
there's and you're going first always
but nobody's in there yet forth till the
bicycle underground scene is tough but
like and I think that's what's cool what
our crew is that like we see things like
that and that is not what happens when
we do shows was a booking us gives us
more juice and workout and it's like
alright we can't be hitting these foods
with [ __ ] when they just opened you
know did two nights at the Novo you know
it gives us that we're after that was
that by but compared to LA more love
with love I feel like Amsterdam's vibe
is mad like you could do a bad one oh
the hip-hop they love this on here they
[ __ ] with more under because you're from
East LA Boyle Heights areas yeah under
when Philippe went there they knew all
about blood and but I filmed all the
[ __ ] there and that's why I was like we
gotta film a Cinco puntos Here I am
talking to some dude from the
Netherlands and he's like oh those
locals like Cinco puntos they know about
that shit's all right we gotta tie all
this into the video and for anyone
listening who hasn't checked out the
video code look it up Latin beast TV on
their channel on YouTube is of Eva
mezcal peyote cactus have Felipe come
and do a dope cameo and got the crew in
there so your album too right yeah thank
you I just dropped me solstice with the
homie nug live shut up that's a neglect
yeah did all that shout out to create
Digimon pub for a distribution but
solstice has been awesome and how's the
album been doing yeah people loved it
honestly I sold out I just she kind of
represented happens they also give it
like double handed compliment yeah it
was but now that I gave you some money
I'm gonna give you some [ __ ]
but when you hit the stage you could
hear all the woman's scream for her it
was like an energy shift like no but
when she went up on stage the people
were screaming that she sold out her
merch I do that one much too Marcella a
woman did buy a CD the lady who told me
I needed a dress better she was like
think about getting a stylist and a
makeup artist in my brain I went to
Holland Amsterdam then after that you
went somewhere else right New York or I
was in New York for a week I was out
there for a music bleed situation like
in New York we'd situation luckily I got
hooked up with some with some good weed
I went out of Queens the homies family
lives there they actually were like hot
Headz I was like I don't think pothead
to get no do because it's not even like
weed culture they're like that's right
here you see hippies and [ __ ] tie-dye
and weave my [ __ ] got weed em alone
we tattoos like we love weed in
California you know in New York it
wasn't like that
it wasn't even easy to sniff out like
but we got connected so we were pretty
cool when we were in message shoots
there's a weak culture there really ya
know there beagle Rhode Island too but
there is legal like well I was in
Atlanta maybe we were in Atlanta what
three weeks ago and they just like
decriminalized to not be arrested for
weed just like the week before we get
there right and then they're like be
careful though they treat we like crack
out here and we took weed over there
from here we pick it up we took it on
the planes mostly you could take weed on
the plane now at LAX
you're supposed to be landing in a
destination where it's legal that's why
I hit it shops now you
back in the days oh man it'll be done
they were zero tolerance we have two
powers one time there was zero to do two
pounds when a horrible week just like
the brake and slow we breath it feels
crazy [ __ ] after the show bruh
these fools were crazy
it was Edwin and me and this fool right
we just wanna smoke some weed man then
it showed to our room and man they
showed up with two pounds just like
freaked out [ __ ] hard brewing a tire
so it would I have bird beak since I
rode oh it was swag they smoked the cops
are knocking before the hotel guy keys
are knocking we ignore his that dog then
he came back with the cops
and then I said that I play stupid in my
room and then I would say ed was awash
this is my room then he later buy this
you cannot accept him
so everybody left and they told him to
I'm eight - I'll get the [ __ ] out of the
hotel room it you're done for the hotel
room and I fooled you started walking to
the airport bro before we left before
they got there bro we put up the two
bricks under the bed instead of cushions
bro and we [ __ ] made the bed and
shoved it in there and left
so somebody scored on two pounds bro
that's like the beginning of like a
crazy [ __ ] drug movie huh like radio
they would've put it knowing those cops
in the way this the laws were back then
they probably would have broke up the
the marijuana and just gave us all
Alice's and get catch us all a little
bit of long night huh nobody would have
say who they was just here didn't you
have a similar situation with Edwin in
Seattle one time when you're with Paul
Rodriguez or something when you hid in
the bathtub versa yeah we were blazing
it we didn't college we did a show at
the college and the guy who booked up
for the college in Seattle he got so
good
we brought it was Dickey like CAC like
Gonzales no no together with the show
not the brother no but he was at the
show and they tried knocking man and he
answered the door and everybody came
into the room and I was in the shower
bro hiding with a door open a sneak out
every close the curtains dude was a
little disquiet Legnica were so boom man
we have a Google Reno on Saturday and
then Friday with Seattle than the week
before that was terrible so we messed up
bro whatever because he thought the
vouchers work for room service
well work for alcohol alcohol in a blue
champagne bottles and orange juice and
breakfast like he has chef Paris for
three people right there imma feed my
kids
Oh champagne I was like did you have the
per diem you have out your cover don't
call me charge my card read the fine
print every night no silver legacy
casino picked us up at the airport it
was badass stretch limo in there at
Corona and it was ego and Toby took
alcohol to put in a bag put the Jackie
back some more cool and then after night
he puts on the table
alright drink your bottle with maybe one
little later but it's my birthday month
birthday month that's why he's going
crazy [ __ ]
after the show I'll just like [ __ ]
dude I have that debo leg dog scraping -
yeah I just dropped the album last month
bro it's called watch me available
everywhere twelve tracks you know 30
minutes yeah bro mix it master buy my
boy right here mezcal yes I'll do all
your stuff at your studio yes sir sites
all in-house how many people in the coop
I'd say well there were like eight or
nine of you on stage and [ __ ] -
right here right he was all Saturday I
didn't bring them but I can only take
two I really what I really like about of
course your you guys album and really is
whoever does the covers or the artwork
it's always it looks top-notch like you
could - without even knowing who this
person in with a backpack I know there's
gonna be a good album like this photo
enough to ruin his wallet yeah
hers to the yours but like it made it
more mysterious like to find out who is
this person
I don't know who you were I just wanna
know who you are to be a thousand
percent honest I was so like like
shocked that mud cuz muds gave it to you
and it was his CD and then I was like oh
it's a CD and I was hike he shocked like
oh damn like uh is he into R&B like that
cuz that album is definitely more on
this yeah you know so it's you know what
it feels a little bit like diggable
planets used to feel like the yours -
your album like the early [ __ ]
November that I've only listened to the
old one
from Atlanta Oh Outkast Oh Cass
you know try it
but I hear it man I hear it and she
don't definitely hear it on yours
who's that who did the song that uses
the Alice Coltrane Torre era Mukesh
sample somebody even sure I was
culturing sample I don't know like that
song I've never heard that song anywhere
else except Alice Coltrane's album it
was like that's our kind of our song
like kind of it's not really a song
there's no lyrics or anything jazz song
but it's something - it was a piano 46
year old white woman I was so bored
fighting here what we're talking about
that's our recorder record you guys ever
like after you're satisfied with it but
you can go ahead oh there's some other
should I could add it to this you like
that I hate that no matter what you know
what that's like always some people have
it depends on the artist but yeah yeah
it happens to every artist for sure is
this how quick can you pull the trigger
I told you girl I miss you when I'm out
here granny yeah top of my album yours
huh yeah
me and Matt Matt yes my bad son shouts
out too bad soon yeah you know music you
know that song you know with the crew
like we're lucky there's a lot of
diversity like don't sleep sound sounds
like don't sleep like he's just on
another you know wave of the same form
of this hip-hop we all kind of do and
it's it's crazy and you listen to say
stuff and it's you know its own planet
its own harmonies and and and it's crazy
it's dope I'm lucky to just be the food
kind of in the
middle quarterbacking this [ __ ] and
getting their perspective
where's bad max Mad Max is somewhere
right now where's the I probably at home
chilling
what up Mad Max will bring a crew show
that's all y'all it's a whole bunch of
us myself
don't sleep mask out whether the next
show
you have to do that thing outside your
studio that we were doing something
called Friday's on first what we did
open mic freestyling right on 1st Street
people driving by our studios right
after thought now that the next block
over it's like closer to homeboy
industries but right now during the the
winter and stuff we don't do is kind of
code the kids out of school it's more
like a spring and summertime thing but
yeah anyone listening that you got bars
that's the chance where people hit a sub
let me rap let me do this and you know
shows what you got and you know exactly
make it a seasonal thing just for you
know what's so bull what's your what's
your instagram my instagram is ZZ ay9 to
say 92 you can stream solstice on all
music platforms you can title google
play whatever you want to do and I also
host the OTR radio segment which I would
like to get y'all's okay we couldn't get
there the IOT or radio ad just follow TR
radio okay so yeah you can find me under
at don't sleep on yourself spelled
normal on Twitter 92 don't sleep on
Facebook and you cruise got an album out
right now you'll find that on all
platforms yeah alright now I'm a scout
Viva mezcal Instagram ELT our network
you'll find all of us don't where to
find that video to that you made that
yeah you guys were supposed to come on
like a month ago we kept having to push
you guys for different reasons and so I
feel bad cuz it was supposed to be right
before the video came right you know but
you know shots all you guys came through
super clutch on for that video got a lot
of hits from his post they've got a lot
of love
it's been amazing the beautiful day - it
was awesome yeah um searching on YouTube
it's Viva mezcal peyote cactus on Latin
bees TV subscribe to them they're super
dope - they they're doing like a channel
all Chicano rap and it's kind of like
what pocos better locals used to do
right yeah yeah and and even then like
people probably wouldn't put us in that
category but at the same time like we
are Chicanos that rap
what the [ __ ] by definition we know
they're a little more old-school I'd say
but yeah I wonder we could contact them
and have them play them check us out and
check out that video and you know thank
you guys shut up tomorrow
Gru's go Lisa he said we'll be a lyrical
beast I was a lead singer of a band
it was alternative bad because this was
1990 called Wallaroo south we were the
part of the date and music scene where
Brainiac Brainiac Brainiac and also
breeders the breeders
that's my wall aroo south and in fact my
roommate stole my guest spot on the
breeders album she got the voicemail on
the machine
you know we don't talk all that were
Facebook friends now how they go down I
didn't even find out about it after one
of our mutual friends told us and she
had erased the message Mario picture
listen to the message with a little fur
coat on way at a club called Canal
Street Tavern which was on a little
street called Canal Street in Ohio and
it was a historic area and anyway this
guy anyway that place is he just closed
the owner died but so much musical
history with everybody everybody played
there and it was that small like nose
that didn't play there but it was a
small they are from Dayton oh the whole
California whole the LA sound is from
Dayton Roger Troutman is from my is
where yeah California fool podcast a big
chopper basically tow yeah man don't
sleep on his ass okay other side but see
that's not the original because I had
the original as it came out it didn't
have all this these are the new ones in
Oh better I bought it when the movie
came out it didn't look like that yeah
yeah it was it used to be like a rope
the X yeah first time I ever saw my scar
this dude was dressed as Santa
we did a toy drive and they needed
someone to dress up as a girl has asked
my skinny ass to do it how do I pillow
that's cuz Joe Rogan is has a bigger
audience than we do for real but anyway
be real would let us play his music
because he's Felipe's friends yeah hey
shove it to be real
alright goodnight let's go Christian
that shirt you can get a flea breeze
WorldCom slash shop you only until
November November homie later fools turn
out to Ted Martinez from Reno faithful
listen you homeboy and shout out to your
star for showing up see you guys next
time man things for that pre row